[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today what's up
Dan
how are you how are you dude we are
rocking on to the Breaking Dawn my
brother what's up
uh question I got for you
um I've been divorced for about about
seven years and uh my current girlfriend
I've been dating her since
um I've been divorced uh for about seven
years
uh just kind of curious she's you know I
guess traditional and I am too in since
but she you know had been pushed to get
married
um I don't have anything against
marriage or anything even though I've
been divorced
but I guess kind of my main issue with
it is you know I just
um
I became you know wealthy here you know
recently uh probably in the last you
know five years uh by I had my own
company uh that I run and I'm very
successful at it and
um it just it just makes me think of you
know if that's a smart move I I've been
through the court system it's not fair
it's really not fair for anybody you
know they're just bloodthirsty you know
tyrants
and I don't really ever want to be in
that situation ever again
um you know I know you can do prenups
and whatnot but in the end those things
are you know like toilet paper in a
sense I mean I mean they're not but but
here let's let's
what is it about your girlfriend of
seven years
that you don't trust
well it's not that I don't trust it is
it is it is you don't trust her
because you built a life for almost a
decade with her yet over here
your languages I've become wealthy so
you've created a life of your own inside
of this seven year relationship
why don't you trust her
is it because you got burned bad with
your ex
and you're dragging that old
relationship well actually I did no okay
I didn't get burned at all through my ex
I actually got burned from my parents
okay and it's still kind of ongoing in a
sense but
um it's just it you know in a sense it
it's it I I don't know I just I I have
this life that you know I want to travel
the world and do these things and and
I'll be able to do that and it's not
responsibility both Jade and I have
traveled the world with our spouses
and it's been infinitely better than
traveling around by ourselves yeah
because when I went I wasn't like Sam
this is what I can afford to do sorry
you can't come because you can't afford
to do that
I wasn't like I'm gonna ride on this
plane you ride on that plane and I'm
gonna stay in this hotel because I can
afford it and you stay in that hotel uh
that's you know a couple Stars smaller
and I get to eat at this restaurant
because I can afford it but you've got
to order the side salad do you see how
kind of crazy that sounds
yeah I understand and I've been
wrestling with that for years you know
but it's like it's also a thing too
where it's like you know I've rest stuff
and I've worked my ass off to get you
know where I'm at and I don't want to
give that up and like but okay let's
stop right there though stop right there
challenge that thought Give It Up to who
is the woman you've been with for seven
years the kind of person that will take
you for everything she'll do you wrong
she'll cheat on you she'll steal from
you and take half of your stuff and take
off is that who she is no she no that's
no okay then why are you carrying that
story around because I can't wait to get
wealthy with my wife as my partner
I can't wait
because I've met a bunch of miserable
wealthy single dudes
and I understand
I've been taught that you know I've
worked so hard and so long and it's an
addition but she's been with you she's
been with you for for for all five of
those years well can I can I pull
another thread on this
um well the first question I have is how
wealthy are you
well I'm 41.
um you know I don't know I'd say
probably like 1.2 1.5 okay good someone
in there yeah the thing is but a lot of
my wealth is in my company because
everything I have I own of course and
you know I own my house I own my cars I
don't know I hate loans I absolutely
hate loans and so refuse to ever get
along and that's the that's the that's
the threat I want to pull something
about what you're saying about you you
believe the opposite is true about her
because you keep saying how much of a
hard worker you are and how much you
hate debt that's making me believe that
you that's why I want to know more about
the fiance because you're not married
yet so you don't have to do anything yet
but
do you uh if you can be honest I don't
know if she listens to the show but is
there a part of you that's like hey I
feel like she's
not a hard worker I feel like she
doesn't have the same views as me on
dead and money like can I pull that
thread a little bit
no she's she's actually a hard worker
she really is but it but in life to be
successful you have to work harder on
yourself than on your job is what Jim
Rome would say and I'm a fluent listener
of him I never thought I'd be ever taken
advice from a dead man before but the
guy was was amazing I I listened to a
lot of this stuff you know uh I think
you need to I think you need to break up
with your girlfriend today
you you don't think that you guys are on
the same level Setter free
because I don't I don't I I know I know
you're not going to and I know I'm just
a knucklehead on a podcast I get that on
the radio
but you don't trust her
you don't have a you want to have this
this life that you're creating alone
yet have her as a hood ornament
you you say I'm not trying to do that I
I think I know I think we're able to
build you know as a team but you you
keep saying I I've built this money I've
done this stuff this is mine I don't
want anyone to take it from me
and you've been with the same woman for
seven years and and let me add to that
what I would be listening for let me
juxtapose it with what I would be
listening for on a healthy side and John
you're you're the guy who knows this so
you tell me if I hear someone talk about
their soon-to-be spouse
I also I don't hear them say well I do
this I do this I hear them say oh man
and my husband he's so good at holding
me accountable and I'm not great with
this but he's so good with that and even
though I'm you know this is one of the
things I'm good at but he adds so much
to the equation like you're constantly
balancing each other out I haven't heard
you say one good thing about her you
haven't said or one thing that she
brings to the table or how she's an
asset like I'm looking for that sort of
language so well I mean she is you know
the other thing too is is you know I
have you know two girls that are almost
grown and she has you know two boys that
are almost grown here's the the here's
the equation that I'm really stuck in
I'm just having contemplations about
really the whole thing is my business
hey I need to get a commercial you know
shop okay I need I need a big place
because I've been running this out of my
house and I I've exploded my house I
have it my house is is my work okay and
it's just it's too much and so I have to
sell and I need to move forward with
this and I've been kind of wanting to
move to you know like either Tennessee
or Texas or something because that's I
just you know got a calling to go to
either one of those two places I really
loved Tennessee been here many times
yeah yeah get to the get to get to what
you're talking about so you know she
doesn't really want to move okay that's
it right there that's it right there
that's it right there unless he's
married unless she's married which I
understand I I totally understand you
don't want to marry her you don't want
to be America and you're not you should
not marry her just to get you to come
with her
you should not marry her for that no no
I understand that but it it's dragging
the kids and you know resetting
everything and and getting a bigger you
know like a you know you got six people
girlfriends girl girlfriend if you're
listening go it's time to leave it's
time to go on yeah
let her go here's why
you've been with the same person for
seven years you can say what you want
but behavior is a language you don't
trust her you don't want to build a
future with her you're annoyed at how
big the house is going to get you're
gonna have to get a shop and she might
not be called to Texas and she's too
traditional all these things and I
believe you probably didn't get burned
hard and it's it's the worst and your
parents are still a mess you got kids
involved I get it let her go don't drag
her behind the car of your life